many people in britain will of course
want to help ukrainian refugees
so we will make it easier for ukrainians
already living in the uk
to bring their relatives to our
country and though the numbers are hard
to calculate they could be more than two
hundred thousand
and if the worst happens
and president zielenski's government is
no longer able to function in kiev we
must prepare to support them whatever
happens in the weeks ahead and we should
recognize that this crisis will impose
costs on ourselves and on our
electorates the sanctions have
consequences for us as well as for
russia
and no step
is free
from risk
and
whatever
the difficulties ahead
and they may be considerable
this is now the moment for europe to do
something that is long overdue
and that is finally to wean ourselves
off dependence on russian oil and gas
and in the long term reduce our reliance
on fossil fuels from any source at all
all of us must proceed with wisdom
and care
and moderation we have a duty to ensure
that this crisis does not spread
any further
but if we are to have any chance of
ending this nightmare
then putin must understand that his
savagery will be met
with unrelenting economic pressure
and that the west will be united
in supporting ukraine
and that we are ready for a prolonged
crisis
i have no doubt that if the west can
maintain the extraordinary unity that we
have shown so far
if we can press ahead with the strategy
we have set out
of international economic humanitarian
and diplomatic assistance to ukraine
along with defensive weapons
then putin's venture will
ultimately fail
the path ahead will require patience and
resolve
and we must be rational in our response
and recognize
that russia is capable both of
misunderstanding and misrepresenting
what we say
and yet i will not
waver
in my conviction
that however long it takes a sovereign
and independent ukraine will emerge once
again
because putin has stubbed his toe and
tripped on a giant and immovable fact
which is no matter how many troops
and tanks he sends
the ukrainians desire to live in a free
and independent country which something
i think polls will immediately
understand
and in this desire
the uk will always give them
our wholehearted support